debajo hay un plano con los vectores y
b&w ordena las tarjetas de acuerdo a la
cantidad que representen si la tarjeta
no representa ninguna de las tarjetas se
debe quedar sin ordenar de estas
tarjetas que tenemos aquí muy bien y si
te das cuenta aquí tengo el plano y aquí
tengo a mi vector de éste de color azul
es mi vector ven aquí tengo a mi vector
w este de color magenta es mi vector w
y por último aquí tengo a mi vector y
este de color morado es mi vector um y
bueno pues vamos a ver qué dicen las
tarjetas de la izquierda las coordenadas
cartesianas 3 4 ok vamos a ver 1 2 3 y 4
para arriba
1 2 3 4 llegamos justo el punto en donde
acaba el vector de y bueno es que estas
coordenadas cartesianas pueden
representar a un vector si decimos el
punto final en donde acaba el vector
el punto 3,4 y el punto inicial es el
origen si el punto inicial es el origen
es decir la cola del vector y el punto
final es el punto 3 4 es decir la cabeza
del vector entonces podríamos decir que
las coordenadas cartesianas 3,4 este
punto representan el vector b
otra forma de verlo es que el vector b
va a 3 unidades hacia la derecha de
forma horizontal mientras que de forma
vertical va 4 unidades hacia arriba y
por lo tanto ésta está representa al
vector b y lo voy a poner justo aquí
bien ahora vayamos al 5 el 5 bueno pues
es un número y recuerda que un número no
representa un vector no representa un
vector porque aunque tenga magnitud le
hace falta dirección así que no puede
representar al vector ven ahora acá
abajo tenemos la longitud del vector b
por lo tanto 5 tal vez podría
representar la longitud de este vector b
así que vamos a verlo
si representará la longitud de este
vector b entonces esta distancia debería
de ser 5 unidades y cómo podemos saber
si esta distancia de 5 unidades bueno
con el teorema de pitágoras si nosotros
nos fijamos que este lado de aquí vale
123 unidades y este lado de aquí vale
1234 entonces te puedes dar cuenta que
tenemos un triángulo rectángulo de la
forma 345 estos triángulos los hemos
visto varias veces y si no lo recuerdas
lo podemos sacar con un teorema de
pitágoras este lado al cuadrado estrés
al cuadrado lo cuales 9 ok si le sumamos
este otro lado al cuadrado lo cual es 4
al cuadrado lo que me da 16
esto me da de resultado 9 +16 lo cual es
25 lo que es en este otro lado elevado
al cuadrado y por lo tanto esta
distancia si son 5 unidades y entonces
podemos decir que si la distancia del
origen al punto 3,4 son 5 unidades
longitud del vector b son 5 unidades la
magnitud de este vector son 5 unidades y
ahora pensemos en un bueno si te das
cuenta uno ve se parecen muchísimo de
hecho es una traslación de este vector
ven nos movimos cuatro unidades en la
izquierda y una unidad hacia arriba y
tenemos al vector y ahora lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que estos dos
vectores son iguales independientemente
del lugar donde empiecen lo que nos
importa es ver qué es lo que pasa desde
la cola del vector hasta la cabeza del
vector desde el punto inicial hasta el
punto final y si te das cuenta pasó
exactamente lo mismo nos movimos tres
unidades hacia la derecha y subimos
cuatro unidades 1 2 3 4 justo como en el
vector t
por lo tanto el vector 1 y el vector b
tienen la misma magnitud y tienen la
misma dirección por lo tanto son
vectores iguales así que
independientemente de donde empiecen en
este plano cartesiano estos 2
representan el mismo vector y por lo
tanto voy a poner al vector 1 justo aquí
en mi vector b bajemos un poco la
pantalla y ahora falta el vector w
el rector w si nos fijamos en este
vector w vamos a ver qué pasa de su
punto inicial a su punto final si te das
cuenta recorrimos 3 unidades pero esta
vez hacia la izquierda y 4 unidades pero
esta vez hacia abajo es decir recorrimos
tres unidades negativas en el eje
horizontal y cuatro unidades negativas
en el eje vertical y por lo tanto este
vector representa justo la versión
negativa del vector b y del vector 1
pero eso quiere decir que no representa
ni al vector o en el vector b por lo
tanto este vector w se va a quedar sin
categoría se va a quedar sin categoría
porque representa a la versión negativa
del vector b o del vector
pero no lo representa tal cual y
entonces es momento de comprobar nuestra
respuesta y si comprobamos nuestra
respuesta del dibujo estamos bien nos
vemos en el siguiente